in 2007 The Big Bang Theory debuted on
CBS but the sitcom didn't explode in
popularity until reruns hit syndication
since then its season premieres have
routinely right near the top of network
TV ratings and reruns dominate the list
of most watched cable shows but for any
shows this huge there are bound to be
some big bangs behind the scenes too
the pilot reconceptualization the show
that's aired for nearly a decade is very
different from the original pilot Jim
Parsons as Sheldon was originally a
horndog this character was changed to
someone mystified by romance and I have
seen six women naked some of them
weren't even relatives Kaley Cuoco's
Penny was also absent instead the
attractive neighbor was the unfriendly
Katie played by Amanda Walsh Johnny
Galecki as Leonard wore suits instead of
hoodies and there was one other change
the theme song was Thomas dolby's She
Blinded Me With Science CBS passed but
Ash creators Chuck Lori and Bill prady
to rework the show and submit another
pilot they did adding an original theme
by Barenaked Ladies and made it to air
in 2007. the Bernadette vocalization
Bernadette's mousey high pitched voice
and Loud moments of screaming rage don't
come naturally to actress Melissa Rausch
I'm a wonderful girl Nick you're lucky
behind me where are you going
toilet is it okay with you although she
doesn't sound like Bernadette in real
life Raj took her inspiration from a
source close to home her own mother
they'll say things like I went to the
grocery store and I had to return
something they sent me to three
different counters it was a real certain
shirt
paycheck extortion in 2014 production of
the show's eighth season was delayed due
to contract renegotiations between the
cast and Warner Brothers ultimately CBS
renewed The Show for an unprecedented
three seasons keeping it on the air
through 2017 Jim Parsons Johnny Galecki
and Kaley Cuoco each secured a salary of
one million dollars per episode
meanwhile Simon Helberg and Kunal Nair
renegotiated their new contracts
collectively ending up with salaries of
around 750 000 per episode a settlement
was reached the day before their old
contracts expired but the duo would have
reportedly been written out of the show
if they hadn't accepted the deal the
relationship obfuscation Kelly Cuoco has
often appeared in tabloids due to her
brief marriage to tennis player Ryan
Sweden still she avoided the spotlight
during her previous relationship even
though it was with a noteworthy co-star
guoco and Johnny Galecki dated from 2007
to 2009 and kept it a secret from not
only the media but from The Big Bang
cast and crew we totally fell for each
other and just morally wanted to keep it
as close to ourselves best and we had an
amazing relationship but Mayim Bialik
manifestation in the 2008 episode the
bat jar conjecture Sheldon quits the
group's physics bolti Raj James high in
the suggestion for a replacement you
know is apparently very smart is the
goluplay TV's Blossom
she got a PhD in Neuroscience or
something Raj we're not getting TV's
Blossom to join our physics Bowl team
the actress is Mayim Bialik who later
joined the cast as Amy Farrah Fowler
also under consideration for the role
was actress and musician Kate micucci
she was judged out for the part but
producers liked her so much that they
wrote her in anyhow as Lucy the
extremely introverted woman Raj briefly
dates the soft kitty misappropriation
soft kitty warm kitty little Paula fur
so that's where you come in co-creator
Bill Brady says he heard Sheldon's
special calm down song at his daughter's
preschool assuming it was public domain
he added it to the show where it's been
used multiple times and on Big Bang
merchandise in 2015 however the family
of a teacher named Edith Newland sued
CBS allegedly the show lifted lyrics
from new win's 1937 song warm kitty the
main difference the original 1937 lyrics
switched the first two lines from the
song We Now know and love this whole
thing could make for one rich Kitty ah
[Laughter]
debuting on CBS in 2007 The Big Bang
Theory has gone on to become the most
popular sitcom on television here's a
look at some stories and Scandals behind
the scenes of America's favorite sitcom
about science nerds the Big Bang that's
aired for a decade plus is very
different from the pilot episode
presented to CBS in 2006 while he's now
depicted as largely asexual and
mystified by romance Jim Parsons Sheldon
was sexually active in the pilot there
was also no Penny instead the attractive
neighbor role was filled by a tough not
very friendly woman named Katie you make
stupid choices and then you blame
everyone else
you're calling me stupid no I said you
make stupid choices because I'm stupid
well
even the looks were different Johnny
galecki's Leonard mostly wore suits
instead of t-shirts and hoodies there
was one other noticeable difference the
theme song was Thomas dolby's 1983 hit
She Blinded Me With Science CBS passed
but asked creators Chuck Laurie and Bill
prady to rework the show and submit
another pilot they revised it and added
in a new theme song from Barenaked
Ladies which made it to the Network's
fall schedule in 2007. over the years
the show has mined a lot of Comedy from
Bernadette's voice when she's just
talking to Howard or her friends she
speaks in a quiet mousy high-pitched way
but when she gets angry she switches to
loud moments of screaming rage
neither of those voices come naturally
to the actress behind Bernadette Melissa
Roush in fact her regular off-screen
speaking voice is quite normal
Bernadette's voice is very similar to my
mother's
um except without the Jersey accent that
means that when Bernadette would imitate
Howard's late mother who spoke with a
Jersey accent she was likely doing a
fully accurate impression of her mom in
2014 contract renegotiations between the
cast and Warner Brothers delayed
production on the show ultimately CBS
renewed the sitcom for three additional
seasons and the show's three leads Jim
Parsons Johnny Galecki and Kaley Cuoco
each secured a salary of one million
dollars per episode meanwhile the show's
male supporting actors who'd been with
the show since day one also had to
renegotiate their contracts Simon
Helberg and Kunal Nair bargained
collectively and both wound up with
salaries of around 750 000 per episode
that leaves the other two major
long-term Big Bang Theory cast members
Melissa Roush and Mayim Bialik they both
joined the show later on in its run and
up until the 2016-17 season both raked
in a relatively meager two hundred
thousand dollars per episode however for
the show's 11th and 12th Seasons the
highest paid cast members agreed to a
pay cut down to nine hundred thousand
dollars an episode each with the intent
that the extra money went to Rausch and
Bialik making 450 000 an episode in the
early years of The Big Bang Theory
Johnny Galecki and Kaley Cuoco secretly
dated each other concurrent with their
characters budding romantic interest it
wasn't until 2010 well after the couple
amicably split that either said anything
publicly about their time together Cuoco
told company magazine CBS watched that
she had dated Galecki for almost two
years it was such a huge part of my life
and nobody knew about it three years
later Galecki gave his side of the story
to CBS watch We're dear friends still
Kaylee's not just an ex she's a part of
my life I just don't like to speak about
it and not because I'm trying to be
enigmatic I just worry that it will
conflict with people's acceptance of
Leonard and Penny co-creator bill prady
says he first heard Soft Kitty Sheldon's
special calm down song sung at his
daughter's preschool assuming it was in
the public domain he added it to the
show where it's been used multiple times
and on scores of big bang merchandise
soft kitty warm kitty little ball of fur
wait wait let's sing it as a round I'll
start
in December 2015 however the family of a
New Hampshire preschool teacher named
Edith Newland sued CBS for copyright
infringement alleging they lifted lyrics
without permission from a song Newland
wrote in the 1930s called warm kitty the
lyrics of newland's song are nearly
identical however in March 2017 a U.S
District Judge dismissed the suit ruling
that prady hadn't violated any copyright
laws because newland's descendants
couldn't actually prove that they had a
copyright on warm kitty Mayim Bialik
joined the series as neuroscientist Amy
Fowler in season three and very slowly
became a love interest for Sheldon and a
hopelessly devoted BFF to Penny the Big
Bang Theory had been on TV for a while
by then but Bialik hadn't quite managed
to catch an episode Bialik went in to
audition for the show without even
realizing how successful the show was as
of 2016 she claims to have not seen any
big bang episodes produced before she
joined not to mention most of the ones
that she actually appears in every
episode of The Big Bang Theory ends with
a title card from Chuck Laurie he writes
it's a new one each time and while it
only appears on screen for a second or
two he uses it as a sounding board for
his thoughts in 2010 one such card
reported on Lori's discovery of a TV
show from the Eastern European nation of
Belarus called the theorists the sitcom
was about four nerdy scientists who
lived next door to a beautiful blonde
waitress the characters are named
Sheldon Leo hovard Raj and Natasha Lori
was convinced that the theorist was
majorly cribbing from The Big Bang
Theory lawyers at Warner Brothers
television told Laurie there was little
that could be done because the
production company responsible for the
theorist was owned by the Belarusian
government but the show was eventually
canceled anyway in 2011 a photographer
spotted a tiny organism in the Brunswick
River in the Australian state of New
South Wales the photographer knew it was
a jellyfish but couldn't readily
identify it so he sent his photos to
jellyfish expert Dr Lisa Ann Gershwin
after two years of research Gershwin and
her colleague taxonomist Peter Davey
confirmed that the 15 millimeter
creature was a previously undiscovered
jellyfish as one of the discoverers
Gershwin got to help name the species
and she went with Bazinga ryaki the
first part of the name is an obvious
reference to Sheldon Cooper's
catchphrase Cry of Triumph
Bazinga
I have an override switch in 2013
biologists from a university in Brazil
announced the discovery of a newbie the
Orchid B it so closely resembles another
species of bee the euglasa ignita that
the researchers decided to go ahead and
give the Orchid B its own official
scientific name of euglasa bazinga
Sheldon most often uses Bazinga as a
kind of gotcha when he tricks someone or
plays a prank on them where did you get
them
what Bazinga I don't care
the biologists thought the word was a
perfect way to describe such a tricky
bee that makes it when a few insects on
Earth to ever be named after a sitcom
catchphrase The Big Bang Theory
showrunner released a statement in
response on behalf of the fictional
honoree Sheldon would be honored to know
that euglasa Bazinga was inspired by him
in fact after Mothra and Griffins bees
are his third favorite flying creatures
Jim Parsons occasionally sputtered
utterance of bazinga is a classic TV
catchphrase that ranks with the all-time
great t-shirt worthy TV Expressions such
as Cowabunga or no soup for you it's
Sheldon's preferred term of Triumph for
a well-executed prank on his scientists
friends the phrase and the proper time
to say it is a direct carryover from The
Big Bang Theory writer's room staff
writer Stephen Ingle who wrote for the
show in 2008 and 2009 loved to set up
fun and innocuous practical jokes to rib
the other scribes co-creator Bill prady
explained the origins of the catchphrase
at a 2013 Paley Fest event that was
Stephen's word for gotcha and he would
use it in the writer's room when the Big
Bang Theory was getting off the ground
in the mid-2000s former Child Superstar
Macaulay Culkin was in the midst of a
comeback he'd ended a long Hiatus with
appearances in two indie films the
religious satire saved and the club kid
murder mystery party monster Big Bang
Theory producers wanted very much to be
in business with the former Richie Rich
and Kevin McAllister Culkin guested on
The Joe Rogan Experience Podcast in 2018
and told Rogan no I said like no because
it was kind of like the way the pitch
was was kind of just like all right
these two like astrophysicist nerds and
then a pretty girl lives with them
ewinks like you know
that was the pitch
Culkin didn't reveal which character he
would have played but he did add that he
had to reject producers overtures two
more times The Big Bang Theory just
loves to insert musical sequences now
and then to break up the setup wisecrack
laughs formula and whenever possible
they let the actors perform their own
musical stunts that works out because a
number of the cast members know their
way around an instrument in the 2013
episode the romance resonance Bernadette
gets quarantined which leads to Howard
leading the whole Big Bang group in a
performance of a special song he wrote
for her if I didn't have you life would
be blue I'd be Doctor Who without the
Tardis is it weird
the actual composers of the song arcade
micucci and Ricky Lindholm of the comedy
musical Duo Garfunkel and Oates Helberg
sang and accompanied himself on
keyboards and it only took him one take
to perform the song Perfectly two other
Big Bang actors learned to play
instruments no small feat just for the
show Sheldon plays the theremin an
electronic instrument used to make those
spooky High high-pitched noises in Old
science fiction and horror movies so Jim
Parsons figured out how to operate one
too it's a little easier to learn than
the harp which Mayim Bialik took up when
the writers decided that her character
should play the heart just before CBS
started airing the 12th season of The
Big Bang Theory CBS announced that the
upcoming batch of episodes would be its
last co-creator and executive producer
Chuck Laurie had gathered the cast in
his office in August 2018 where star Jim
Parsons announced that he was leaving
the show at Seasons in immediately after
Lori told the cast that everyone would
be leaving a season's end because he'd
opted to end the series rather than do
it without Parsons according to deadline
Parsons told Laurie of his decision a
few days before that meeting and plenty
of Executives secretly tried to get
Parsons to change his mind the four-time
Emmy winner may have even turned down as
much as 50 million dollars to stay with
the big bang theory for two more seasons
Penny may be the black sheep of the Big
Bang crew but on at least one occasion
she was more of a big bully actress
Kaylee Cuoco played Penny on The Big
Bang Theory for 12 seasons in a way the
entire series is predicated on her
entrance into the lives of the show's
principal nerds and the various ways she
lives up to and defies the blonde
stereotypes that provide an early source
for the show's unique brand of humor I'm
a vegetarian no except for fish and the
occasional steak I love steak
thank you well that's interesting Penny
makes her debut in the pilot as the
beautiful girl who moves in across the
hall from the brilliant but socially
awkward Caltech scientists Sheldon
Cooper and Leonard hofstetter Leonard
immediately becomes infatuated with the
Cheesecake Factory waitress and wannabe
actress the tough Nebraska farm girl who
prefers wine shoes and celebrity gossip
to video games and comic books embarks
on a nine year will they won't they
relationship with Leonard that ends with
the twosome at last tying the knot in
season 10. much of the humor on The Big
Bang Theory is derived from Penny making
fun of Leonard Sheldon and their friends
for being Geeks and from her own ditzy
and flirty Behavior Penny and Leonard's
unlikely romance is also the butt of
countless jokes reminding the audience
time and again that when Opposites
Attract wacky and weird hijinks ensue
however there are times when it's hard
to ignore that Penny and Leonard are
woefully mismatched infusing the sitcom
with moments that can be hard to watch
in fact season 7 episode 12 contains a
scene in which fans agree that Penny
goes too far in her mistake treatment of
Leonard are you kidding me
in the hesitation ramification penny is
cast on an episode of NCIS after her
scene is cut a depressed and drunk and
Penny tells Leonard she spent 10 years
in California and she has nothing to
show for it Leonard points out that she
has him and Penny tells him he's right
and proposes
let's get married
what when Leonard hesitates Penny gets
upset takes back the proposal and storms
out of Leonard's apartment Leonard
begins to question if he and Penny have
a future together and it's obvious
Leonard is heartbroken throughout the
entire episode Penny treats Leonard
badly particularly when he does
something she perceives as criticism or
rejection fans stick to Reddit to
discuss this episode and specific scene
and their comments do not paint a
flattering picture of penny with
everyone firmly on team Leonard one user
wrote I believe Leonard did the right
thing by saying no to Penny's drunken
proposal if he did say yes to the
proposal I think he would feel like he
would have been taking advantage of her
in her drunken State another redditor
was particularly unkind in their
assessment of Penny writing penny is a
legitimate alcoholic I don't remember an
episode where she hasn't had a drink is
there one another user went in on Penny
further writing penny is selfish rude
and sometimes cruel to the man she's
supposed to love Leonard doesn't seem to
have any dignity left it's a pretty
harsh take on our towheaded heroine
especially considering the delicate
State the episode finds her in it's
worth noting that penny has just
experienced a major career
disappointment one that quite reasonably
might make her a tad sensitive to any
additional rejection in her life perhaps
Penny's reaction to Leonard's hesitation
to accept her proposal on The Big Bang
Theory would have generated more
sympathy from viewers if fans didn't
already have issues with their
relationship there is no shortage of
Reddit chatter devoted to the topic of
Penny and Leonard's partnership and why
penny is a terrible partner for Leonard
one Reddit thread simply titled I hate
Penny consists of Ruthless takedowns of
the character as one user put it she
constantly fights with Leonard and walks
all over him considering Penny's
negative behavior after Leonard doesn't
respond the way she wants him to after
she asks him to marry her this opinion
is not without Merit Penny attempts to
exploit Leonard to make herself feel
better while also taking advantage of
his feelings for her Leonard actually
proposes to Penny long before she pops
the question he first asks her in The
Big Bang Theory season 5 episode 23 the
launch acceleration and she responds
with frustration and anger in part
because of Leonard's poor timing so just
the Heat of the Moment
is oh yeah just like that not will you
marry me as you might be able to guess
she ultimately tells him no as some
disappointed fans interpret it in
Penny's mind rejection is only
understandable or acceptable if she's
the one saying no
after 12 years in 279 episodes The Big
Bang Theory wrapped up its run in 2019
and the final shows were crammed full of
references to past storylines and
characters here's a look at everything
that went down and why it all matters to
the overall Big Bang Theory Universe
long-running sitcom finales almost
always involve a big dramatic event
characters move away or a romantic will
they or won't they thread and happily or
some other big goal is achieved for a
show like The Big Bang Theory about
adults who have almost all married and
become successful in their professions
that kind of big change wouldn't have
run true instead the writers found an
ending that made sense for its
world-class scientist characters while
also resolving a plot line that
stretched throughout the show's 12th and
final season physicist Sheldon Cooper
and his wife neuroscientist Amy Farrell
Fowler win the Nobel Prize for physics
for their work on super symmetry it's
the ultimate goal of every scientist and
one Sheldon specifically and frequently
mentioned throughout the series so you
really think that I'm the kind of man
who would sell out his partner for the
chance of winning a Nobel Prize
are you
boy I hope not receiving this honor also
gives the show an excuse for a big
destination finale so you guessed it the
whole gang decides to accompany Sheldon
and Amy to the Nobel awards ceremony in
Sweden over the course of nearly 300
episodes The Big Bang theory developed
quite a few running gags recurring Bits
And even Unsolved Mysteries the finale
gave fans what they wanted delivering on
those lengthy setups and wrapping things
up nicely along the way viewers finally
learned why Leonard dresses the way he
does Forever sporting at least two
layers on his upper body despite living
in sunny California Leonard reveals that
he's always rocking a hooded sweatshirt
because he's constantly chilly this of
course is Sheldon's fault he insists
that the thermostat be kept in an
uncomfortably low temperature the show's
longest running gag is also resolved
after years of walking up and down the
stairs a mechanical Miracle occurs with
a simple ding Penny emerges from the
elevator that's been out of order since
the first episode aired in 2007.
can't believe it they finally fixed the
elevator
plus a couple of the show's most
predominant recurring characters get
cameos in the final episodes doing
exactly the type of things that made
them so beloved John Ross Bowie reprises
his role as Sheldon's workplace Nemesis
Barry a prank calls a very nervous
Sheldon as he waits to hear from the
Nobel committee also the perpetually
unlucky Stewart shows up for a quick
scene Howard and Bernadette video chat
with him as they realize he was the
wrong person to babysit their children
okay so everyone's happy and healthy
well that depends what's that mean
how many teeth did Hallie have when he
left even a double episode with nearly
45 minutes of running time however
wasn't enough to wrap up every storyline
from the show's extensive past when the
series began in 2007 all four male main
characters were single and socially
awkward by the end three of them Sheldon
Leonard and Howard Found Love and are
happily married that just leaves Raj the
most loved Lauren of them all is the
soul Bachelor the series ends with Raj
just as single is when it started
although he almost got married in the
final season luckily there may be a
glimmer of hope for his love life on the
flight over to Sweden Raj ends up in a
seat next to Sarah Michelle Geller who
is TV's Buffy the Vampire Slayer somehow
he manages to convince her to attend the
Nobel ceremony with him which was a huge
surprise to everyone
is that Buffy the Vampire Slayer
[Laughter]
and as for the Big Bang Theory's most
enduring question well it didn't get
answered and it probably never will
before she became Mrs Penny hofstadter
Penny's last name was never mentioned
even when relatives visited writers were
careful to let the mystery remain
unsolved a huge amount of the show's
stories jokes and character quirks
revolved around Sheldon being picky
self-centered arrogance controlling and
unabashed about all of it I'm sorry that
I upset you yes ask me how I feel about
that
foreign
most viewers have probably wondered why
Amy and the others can tolerate such an
intolerable man throughout the finale
almost every character has finally had
enough of Sheldon's behavior and they
let him know it Leonard confronts him
when after being told that penny is
pregnant Sheldon's merely glad that
she's got morning sickness and not a
virus that he might catch when Sheldon
tells Amy that he doesn't intend to be
so mean she drops the bomb that this
obliviousness is the only reason why his
entire group of friends hasn't walked
out on him Sheldon's behavior is so
terrible that Howard Bernadette Leonard
and Penny all make plans to head home
early and skip the ceremony but this is
an upbeat Network sitcom so that's not
gonna happen the whole gang is in the
audience when Amy and Sheldon accepts
science's highest honor both characters
deliver touching speeches one speaks to
the show's Legacy and the other provides
a happy tear-jerking Moment The Big Bang
Theory casually demystified science for
millions and probably inspired more than
a few kids to be scientists in real life
actress Mayim Bialik has a PHD in
Neuroscience from UCLA reflecting this
passion her character Amy gives a
powerful speech encouraging young girls
who dream of a career in science to go
for it no matter what
it is the greatest job
in the world
and if anybody tells you you can't don't
listen then it's Sheldon's turn stun
that his friends have stuck around to
cheer him on after his terrible Behavior
he ignores the novel-length
self-aggrandizing speech he prepared
instead he speaks from the hearts and
thanks his friends and wife for their
years of support Sheldon also apologizes
for not always being a great friend and
lets them know how he truly feels
but I want you to know
in my way
I love you all
this beloved series could very well have
ended in that Auditorium in Sweden but
that was just the show's climax it
needed an epilogue at its heart The Big
Bang Theory is a show about friendship
and how powerful it is when Misfits grow
up and create their own families of
Kindred Spirits so much of the series
consisted of the seven featured
characters hanging out in the main
apartment set Gathering each evening to
eat takeout and that was the Perfect
final image for The Big Bang Theory a
group of close friends casually hanging
out as the camera eases away and the
series Fades into TV history
if you're a fan of The Big Bang Theory
perhaps you can answer this simple
question for us what exactly is Benny's
last name
well
we imagine you're totally stumped right
now that's because unlike the other main
characters Penny doesn't actually have a
last name at least not a last name we
ever heard on the show sure she became
Penny hofstadter after she married
Leonard but her maiden name Still
Remains a big mystery even after the
season finale aired in May 2019. many of
us waited and waited but we never got
the big reveal and it's entirely likely
that we never will this Omission
evidently wasn't an oversight at least
not through the entire run of the show
as it turns out the creative minds
behind the show made an executive
decision to leave Penny's surname an
unsolved mystery evidently unaware that
this is exactly the kind of thing that
keeps us awake at night Jack Laurie the
co-creator of The Big Bang Theory once
handed that Penny's last name might be
Barrington but if that's true it was
certainly never mentioned on the program
or anywhere else for that matter so he
may have been trolling his fans as
executive producer Stephen molaro
explained during a March 19 WonderCon
panel eventually we got nervous and
superstitious about giving her a last
name it will always be her married name
hofstadter he said something similar to
vulture in 2013. what name could we
possibly pick that would be satisfying
at this point you know I don't think we
will reveal it we're kind of a
superstitious lot here we've made it
this far without knowing Penny's last
name I think we're good not finding out
isn't it well I mean what you find
and the plot thickens in 2017 actress
Kaley Cuoco revealed that she didn't
even want to know Penny's last name
telling CBS it's kind of a personal
thing it feels like a jinx we haven't
said it for so long I feel like if we
said it the world will explode kuoko
tauntingly goes on to reveal that she
has some idea about what Penny's maiden
name is but don't get too excited
because she never spills the beans
instead she clamps down and outright
refuses to share her top secret Intel
with us does she also think Penny's last
name is Barrington why the veil of
secrecy does Penny have a last name
that's simply too embarrassing to say
out loud for the love of God what is
Penny's last name it's really anyone's
guess at this point and it sounds like
kuoko is all about keeping this Burning
pop culture mystery alive in fact at the
wrap party for the series finale in May
2019 she even admitted
I kind of love it so many things are
revealed in the last few episodes you
get a lot of satisfying moments but I
kind of love that we'll never know her
last name could this glaring Omission
have something to do with how Penny was
conceived in the first place as Newsweek
reports she was written into the pilot
at the very last minute an attempt to
replace a character named Katie who was
originally intended to be the girl
living across the hall from Sheldon and
Leonard well test audience is evidently
really hated this Katie and they thought
her personality was way too Brash for
the show whatever that means in the
context of The Big Bang Theory
allow me to explain it to you in your
language nerdish to address these
concerns the writers started from
scratch and eventually created Penny as
a replacement for Katie Cuoco had
originally auditioned for the part and
she was subsequently called back to
audition for Penny spoiler alert she
totally landed the role
since Penny was added into the show so
late in the game perhaps the writers and
creators totally forgot to give her a
last name hey it happens and throughout
the run of the series perhaps they
simply never found the right opportunity
or right gag to make the big reveal
something memorable much like the
enduring popularity of The Big Bang
Theory this is one mystery we may never
get to the bottom of
whether you are a fan from way back or
just got into the series when it was
added to HBO Max The Big Bang Theory
remains one of the most binge-worthy
sitcoms in recent memory with a story
that runs 12 seasons and 279 episodes
the series makes for many hours of
enjoyment as well as plenty of
opportunities to spot potential plot
holes and continuity errors that's to be
expected with any long-running series
though and spotting gaps in logic or
very specific errors can even add an
extra level of enjoyment to a re-watch
fans of The Big Bang Theory certainly
seem to think so as they often take to
Reddit to share the plot holes they
uncover deep in the show's history
unraveling how these mess-ups affect the
rest of the series then also adds to the
fun of seeking them out one error
recently uncovered by ecowide redditors
carries big implications for the
backstory of Sheldon Cooper not only on
The Big Bang Theory but also the prequel
series young Sheldon there's an issue
with Sheldon's age and it isn't that the
show hasn't told us when born rather the
problem is that the show tells us when
Shonen was born but later contradicts
that date it was referenced multiple
times that Sheldon and his twin sister
Missy were born on February 26 1980.
however as Reddit user dgnac discovered
the map of Sheldon's various life
accomplishments doesn't quite add up if
one examined Sheldon's own accounting of
his past in the first season episode the
Luminous fish effect after he gets fired
from his job Sheldon declares he's not
interested in getting it back saying
I've spent the past three and a half
years staring at grease boards full of
equations before that I spent four years
working on my thesis before that I was
in college and before that I was in the
fifth grade now another established fact
is that Sheldon being the difficult
genius he is started college when he was
11 years old a major plot point in young
Sheldon however dgnac notes that when
that timeline is added up four years for
college four for his PhD thesis and
three and a half working before the
beginning of the series that puts his
age in the Luminous fish effect at only
22. that's about five years shy of how
old he should be at that point which is
27. this timeline fumble is likely
nothing more than the result of a
mistake in the script but it's also not
the first time the show has had trouble
pinning down exactly when Sheldon was
born the show also goofed on Sheldon's
astrological sign whether or not you
believe that someone's astrological sign
has any correlation to their personality
Western astrology does work off of a
specific set of dates to categorize
people into one of 12 specific signs
however in the case of The Big Bang
Theory the lines between someone's
actual birthday and their sign
occasionally gets blurred for example in
the season 1 episode The Peanut reaction
penny is talking with Sheldon and
Leonard about the group's various zodiac
signs she says I was going to do
everybody's until Sheldon went on one of
his typical psychotic rants after
Sheldon repeats his rant against the
legitimacy of astrology Penny responds
blah blah blah typical Taurus
the funny line but Sheldon's February
26th birthday makes him a Pisces not a
Taurus Penny herself even confirms this
fact in the season 8 episode the
intimacy acceleration after learning
that it's Sheldon's birthday she
responds that was so funny
never would have pegged you
all seem like it's fixating extra hard
on Sheldon's birthday so to switch
things up have a look at the time the
show couldn't decide where Sheldon was
born instead of when Sheldon's mother
Mary Cooper became one of the Big Bang
Theory's best love supporting characters
because of her texas-sized personality
and the fact that she and Sheldon are
comically different people one of the
first things that viewers learn about
Mary is that she gave birth to Sheldon
in a rather unconventional location this
occurs in the episode the Luminous fish
effect wherein Mary comes to town to try
and check Sheldon out of the depressive
episode he falls into after losing his
job while talking to his friends about
her son Mary says I tell you I love the
boy to death but he has been difficult
since he fell out of me at the Kmart
just one season later though viewers
were already given an alternative
location for Sheldon's birth in the
season 2 episode the lizard Spock
expansion Sheldon asserts that he was
born at the fictional Lawrence Memorial
Hospital not at a department store so
after all that here's the lowdown on
Charlotte's birth he was born on
February 26th and sometime in April
between the years 1980 through 1985 at
the Kmart inside the Lawrence Memorial
Hospital glad that's all cleared up
what if Penny was hiding a deep dark
secret from the guys since the very
first episode
too hard to believe well keep watching
because we're diving into a fan theory
that changes everything if you really
think about it we barely know anything
about the Big Bang Theory's Penny who
until she marries Leonard in season 9
doesn't even have a last name she's
beautiful and blonde but that doesn't
mean her supposed acting career is going
anywhere she can somehow afford to live
in the same apartment building as
several working scientists in spite of
her waitress salary you realize penny
that the technology that went into this
arm will one day make unskilled food
servers such as yourself obsolete
really they're gonna make a robot that
spits on your hamburger all the while
her character seems to have nothing at
all in common with Leonard and his
friends yet she still spends almost all
of her time hanging out with them eating
Chinese food and listening to them nerd
out about subjects she doesn't seem to
grasp it speaks to a crisis in the very
foundation of the show's premise that
these inconsistencies are never probed
let alone explained look too hard at the
character Penny and based on the sheer
improbability of this one woman's
choices and traits you'll see all the
cracks that should have brought the
entire structure of the series crumbling
down
fortunately there is a fan theory that
provides an explanation for all of these
apparent plot holes and its implications
are pretty darn wild to comprehend
according to this fan Theory first
posited by Reddit user number Theory and
picked up by Screen Rant it's quite
possible that penny is secretly a spy
that's right move over the Americans
because Chuck Lori's got an entirely
different story to tell about a deep
cover agent living among her
unsuspecting marks
the theory ties into the notion that the
federal government has been spying on
Sheldon and Leonard ever since the
latter broke up with Joyce Kim a woman
who was revealed to be a North Korean
spy in the episode the staircase
implementation an upset Leonard causes
an explosion that takes out the
building's elevators which may not
interest local authorities for very long
but coupled with the Kim incident very
well could have drawn the attention of
the federal government aware of Leonard
and Sheldon's knowledge of a rocket fuel
project they simply sent penny in to
monitor both men according to the theory
it sounds absurd but it actually ties up
all of the lingering confusion about her
lifestyle think about it Penny without
even an identifiable last name has been
sent into the men's lives to observe
their Antics this explains why she
spends so much time with two guys who
don't share her interests why she
doesn't have any friends of her own how
she can afford an apartment without a
roommate and why there's a lack of
traction in her so-called acting career
when you were telling Kevin about your
acting career did you mention your
long-running role as waitress in a local
production of the Cheesecake Factory all
obvious violations of Occam's razor
aside sometimes it's the explanation
that actually explains everything that's
worthy of consideration unlike the real
life Big Bang Theory ironically enough
you can think of it as a unified theory
of Penny no cops be cool if you're still
having trouble wrapping your head around
the possibility that penny is The Spy
Next Door then consider this despite
Penny's lack of multiple phds The Big
Bang Theory makes it clear she's not an
idiot far from it in fact without the
slow reveal of Penny's intelligence over
the course of her long character Arc
would her relationship with the
objectively brilliant Leonard even work
maybe just maybe she plays it all babe
in the woods whenever the boys descend
into science talk just to keep their
guard down maybe she feigns a total lack
of understanding to lure this apartment
full of useful idiots into a false sense
of security if they knew right from the
get-go that Penny understood even a
fraction of what they were saying maybe
they would have been more guarded with
the details of their work her
performative ignorance provides them
with just the level of comfort they need
to spill each and every classified being
all the while if this theory is to be
believed at least Penny could be
carefully recording any and all
information that may be of interest to
Federal intelligence now go back and
watch the entire series from the
beginning with this new understanding
it's a totally different show that's
about it
that's the story of penny
throughout its 12th season run the Big
Bang Theory remained a ratings and
cultural Juggernaut but just because
something is popular does not
automatically mean it is perfect here
are some questionable things we ignore
in The Big Bang Theory fans who only
started watching The Big Bang Theory
after Howard married Bernadette might
not realize how big of a creep Howard
was before settling down with the love
of his life in the earliest Seasons
Howard was basically a predator and
Penny was often the unfortunate
recipient of his unwanted attentions one
of the most unsettling throwaway jokes
from early on in the show was when
Howard asked Penny if she would have
opened the door if she knew he was
standing outside to this Penny replies
not since I found out the teddy bear you
gave me had a webcam in it
foreign
this was not even the only time Howard
tried to use technology to spy on an
attractive woman without her consent he
and Raj went to Great Lengths to figure
out the location of the house from
America's Next Top Model where all the
models were staying even making illegal
use of a government satellite in the
process Howard's Antics are always
played for laughs but it is clear that
his behavior rubs every woman he meets
the wrong way this was confirmed when he
tried to kiss Penny and she punched him
in the eye in retaliation the truth is
if the show was even slightly realistic
a lot of the stunts Howard pulled to try
to get with women could have landed him
in jail The Big Bang Theory was a show
that thrived on making jokes about
stereotypes as the show's rare main
character who's also non-white Raj was
often the subject of mockery based on
his Indian Heritage over the years many
jokes were made about Raj coming from a
country that is poor and overpopulated
where animals are considered magic and
where the culture and religion were
silly
foreign
that's very offensive
after a Time the show eased up on the
Indian joke somewhat but the attacks
against Raj became more personal every
aspect of the character's life from his
lack of a romantic partner to personal
interests and physical appearance were
constantly made fun of worse it was
usually raja's best friend Howard making
those jokes to the extent that the two
had a brief falling out because Raj did
not like the way Howard constantly
bullied him the end of the show did
nothing to give Raj any sort of a
Redemption Arc he remained the only main
character to not have a special someone
when the series ended due to facing one
bitter disappointment in his love life
after another he was also shown to have
become much more dependent on his
parents for financial support and
essentially replaced Sheldon as the
man-child unable to function as a mature
adult before Jim Parsons made Sheldon
the star of the show The Big Bang Theory
was mainly about Leonard trying to
desperately date penny in time after
many false stops and starts Leonard and
Penny finally became a couple when they
tie the knot and move in together but
that was far from the happily ever after
scenario that fans had been expecting
soon after their marriage fans started
noticing that Penny was becoming more
than a little mean towards Leonard she
belittled his accomplishments made fun
of his relationship with his mother and
frequently made fun of him in group
settings when Penny and Raj were
discussing how Howard constantly makes
mean-spirited comments about Raj he
points out that Penny does the same
thing with Leonard she agrees with that
assessment but perhaps the biggest sign
that all was not well in Penny and
Leonard's marriage due to Penny's
attitude occurs in the episode the
romance recalibration at first penny
thinks Leonard has stopped trying in
their relationship since getting married
but then Leonard points out the opposite
I'm the one who's made all the effort in
this relationship since day one please
tell me what more I could do
later seasons of The Big Bang Theory
gave us strong female characters and
story lines thanks to the addition of
Amy and Bernadette to the main cast but
this only serves to highlight how the
early seasons of the show were only
interested in presenting women as the
mysterious other almost like they were
aliens the central premise upon which
the show itself was built had to do with
the awkwardness of the main four male
characters in social situations
particularly pertaining to women Howard
acts like a thirsty creep around females
Raj is literally unable to even speak to
them without getting drunk Sheldon has
no interest in interacting with them and
Leonard perhaps the most normal of the
group can't even ask out Penny or any
other attractive woman due to a
crippling inferiority complex because of
this setup females on the show were all
too often presented as one-dimensional
characters whose only contribution to
the plot was being hot or whether or not
the male characters had a chance of
sleeping with them this trend was summed
up perfectly in the episode The Justice
League recombination when Sheldon
questions whether Penny's Wonder Woman
outfit is authentic enough without a
black wig Howard dismisses his concerns
with the remark
relax no one's going to be looking at
her hair
in a sea of awkward anti-social Geeks
The Big Bang Theory initially presented
Penny as the sole voice of reason the
street smart kind-hearted simpleton did
not mind being friends with geeks and
even helped them open up to the rest of
the world this however is far from the
reality of Penny's relationship with the
guys penny is shown to be clearly aware
of the effect her looks have on Leonard
Raj and Howard and she often uses it to
her Advantage she eats food that the
guys order without paying her share she
steals their Wi-Fi and uses their brains
whenever she needs something technical
done even worse she made Leonard go to
her ex-boyfriend's house to pick up her
things after only knowing him for a few
days leading to Leonard getting bullied
by her ex both him and Sheldon get their
pants taken Leonard what my mom bought
me those pants I'm sorry
it is also shown that penny is aware of
her manipulative Behavior since she
grows insecure when a new pretty girl
moves into their building and proceeds
to use the guys in exactly the same
manner as her The Big Bang Theory is
often held up as an example of a show
that brought the geek way of life into
the cultural mainstream while it is true
that the show is chock full of
references to the most obscure facets of
geek culture how it explores those
facets is more than a little
questionable oftentimes the entire
punchline of a joke is that these grown
men are actually interested in something
so geeky consider the following actual
joke from an actual episode on the show
the fate of doctor whose Tardis will be
decided by A Game of Thrones inspired
death match on the battlefield of
Thundercats vs Transformers
that's it that's the entire joke just a
bunch of references to various sci-fi
and fantasy franchises many times the
show doesn't set up a reference to an
aspect of geek culture using that
reference to create actual humor instead
all too often the entire joke is showing
how obsessed these man children are with
something that's somehow meant for kids
in the hands of a lesser actor Sheldon
would have become the most insufferable
character in the history of Television
it is a testament to Jim Parsons skill
as an actor that he managed to make
audiences fall in love with Sheldon
instead of viewing the character as the
awful awful person he really is from the
start of the show Sheldon has proven
himself time and again to be Petty
selfish vindictive controlling and
callous he constantly makes fun of his
friends for not being as smart as him he
has made several jokes at the expense of
women your ovaries are squirting so much
goofy juice into your brains you don't
even know which way is up
he even showed his assistant Alex
graphic images of human genitals without
her consent some of this Behavior wound
up getting him sexual harassment
accusations at work whenever Sheldon
acts like a complete tool the show makes
it clear that he does so out of
ignorance rather than active malice that
excuse would only work if Sheldon
himself did not take offense when others
act inappropriately towards him but in
those cases Sheldon is always very quick
to take offense clearly Sheldon has a
working understanding of right and wrong
but his dismissive attitude towards the
entire human race including his closest
friends and family makes him indifferent
to any hurt he might cause to others
that is until he is specifically called
out on his behavior over time Leonard
became one of the most pathetic
fictional characters ever created in the
beginning he was shown to allow Sheldon
to walk all over him in terms of their
living arrangements after marriage Penny
replaced Sheldon as the person who
constantly orders Leonard around and
then to cap it all off we meet Leonard's
mother Beverly it would be hard to
overstate just how much emotional abuse
Beverly ejected Leonard to from a young
age she withheld affection turned a
critical Gaze on everything Leonard
tried to do and acted dismissive towards
his achievements to top it all off
Leonard discovers that his mother
subjected him to a number of
psychological experiments from an early
age and published the findings for the
world to see every time I'm around her I
turn into this needy little
eight-year-old boy all of this left deep
scars on Leonard's psyche but in a case
of adding insult to injury Beverly
remains largely indifferent to Leonard's
feelings she often acts as though
Leonard is being unduly emotional and
that she had in fact been a model mother
even though Leonard and Beverly
eventually reached some sort of an
understanding the Damage Done to Leonard
in terms of turning him into a human
doormat will probably never be reversed
Sheldon is openly acknowledged to be a
pretty terrible person because there's
very little artifice in him and he
doesn't try to hide his true nature but
Sheldon has some tough competition in
the biggest douchebag Department from
none other than sweet tiny Bernadette
who is deceptively sneaky about being a
major bully a prime example of Bernie's
hidden nature was seen way back when
everyone thought she was sweetness and
Delight personified Sheldon is trumped
by a physics problem and the rest of the
group are suffering the consequences
when they are all Fed Up Bernie is the
one to stand up to Sheldon she talks to
him like he's a child and sends him to
bed but the true extent of Bernadette's
mean-spirited nature was realized once
her professional life came into focus it
comes to light that everyone at her
office is terrified of Bernadette even
her boss in fact everyone working in the
same building as her collectively
decides to repurpose the handicapped
washroom as Bernadette's private
lavatory after she keeps on using it
this bullying aspect of Bernie's nature
frequently leaks into her private life
in episodes to come so much so the that
even Penny grows wary of accidentally
making Bernadette angry in general it is
repeatedly emphasized just how smart and
capable the male characters are when it
comes to their jobs particularly Sheldon
but just because they have the brains to
be good at their jobs doesn't mean they
have the ethics to go along with it in
fact Leonard Sheldon Raj and Howard
should be in jail for some of the things
they've done while on the job for
instance there was the time when Leonard
almost divulged State secrets to a North
Korean spy to make her sleep with him or
when Leonard Raj and Howard illegally
tested an experimental Rocket Fuel
formula in a public area and blew up
their residential buildings elevator as
a result then there's the time when
Howard crashed the Mars rover space
vehicle while trying to impress a random
girl he met in a bar and let's not
forget when Sheldon and Leonard tried to
illegally procure liquid helium through
a shady contact honestly sometimes you
have to wonder how the guys have managed
to stay out of jail and hold on to their
jobs for so long what scene from The Big
Bang Theory had Mayim Bialik feeling
immensely stressed out and so
self-conscious keep watching to find out
what happy character moment felt like a
nightmare for the actor The Big Bang
Theory was one of television's longest
running and most successful sitcoms
starring Johnny Galecki Jim Parsons
Kaley Cuoco and Mayim Bialik among
others the show featured a bunch of
nerds stumbling through life and love
trying their best to find their own
personal happiness the show was adored
by millions of fans worldwide during its
run running for an astonishing 12
Seasons before finally coming to an end
in 2019 but making the show wasn't
without its difficulties for Bialik
especially when it came to filming the
show's iconic wedding scene Bialik
played the brilliant Dr Amy Farrah
Fowler who meets Dr Sheldon Cooper
played by Parsons on an arranged date
she and Sheldon start out a bit Rocky as
tends to be the case with most
relationships Sheldon gets into
throughout the show romantic or
otherwise but as they get to know one
another the abutting Friendship
eventually turns into something more she
makes him a better man and once he
finally matures just enough to realize
that he proposes at the end of season 11
Amy and Sheldon finally get married but
while fans of the show were jumping for
joy behind the scenes it was extremely
difficult for Bialik to pretend to be a
smiling happy bride in a blog post
published on grok Nation the night
before the episode aired she revealed
that it really affected her on a
personal level because as a divorced
woman it's hard to revisit that moment
in those decisions she also revealed
that prior to filming the scenes she had
been out sick for a month the illness
was treated with antibiotics which
promoted weight gain she wrote that she
quote felt ashamed and that she felt
like people were judging her weight in
appearance despite the fact that she had
no control over it she wrote even though
everyone said I looked beautiful I
didn't feel completely beautiful feeling
down and out regarding her appearance
during her wedding episode of The Big
Bang Theory wasn't the only issue Bialik
had to contend with like many performers
Bialik had been open about her battle
with anxiety she spoke about it at
length during a 2021 episode of her
podcast Bialik breakdown while speaking
with her Big Bang Theory co-star Kevin
Sussman the Alex Ed with acting stuff my
level of anxiety surrounding performing
is
um very very high and unfortunately it's
only heightened when she does
improvisational acting something she was
called upon to do occasionally on The
Big Bang Theory she explained and when
I've tried to do things like improv
things that are very kind of free form I
freeze I literally freeze it's like an
instant knot in your throat it's stuck
and there are tears there like I want to
cry many other celebrities including
Ryan Reynolds and Emma Stone have also
opened up about dealing with anxiety as
individuals who have to perform for a
living even for the most successful
Stars it's not easy and Bialik went on
to discuss how specifically it impacted
her time on Big Bang Theory I've had
this a handful of times when working on
Big Bang Theory when there was a certain
way they wanted a line delivered and I
was like oh okay I got that I'll do that
in the next take and I do it but it's
still not right and sometimes it's like
the audience isn't laughing you know
it's not funny I can usually do about
four takes or five takes before my
throat starts to do that thing while
discussing her social anxiety Bialik
revealed on her YouTube channel that she
has made the decision not to take
medication I choose to
juggle through it and and find new ways
that I can feel Freer to be myself
fortunately there are other ways in
which Bialik manages her anxiety she
revealed that she goes to therapy and
practices meditation she's also a big
fan of weighted blankets it may have
been tough fortunately resources are
available to those who struggle with
anxiety and Bialik was able to do
phenomenally during her time on The Big
Bang Theory back in 2007 collecting
Comics wearing superhero merch and
researching particle physics might have
seemed strictly reserved for nerds it
was the year after the original X-Men
Trilogy had wrapped in movie theaters
and the year that the Toby Maguire
starring Spider-Man trilogy ended with
emo Spidey that September a show about
four geeky scientists and one beautiful
aspiring actress debuted not with a bang
but with a collective
co-created by Two and a Half Men
Mastermind Chuck Laurie and Bill prady
who worked on series like Star Trek
Voyager and married with Children The
Big Bang Theory Had Creative powerhouses
behind it but it didn't take off like a
homemade bottle rocket until a bit later
in the game The Big Bang Theory was
riffing on nerd culture before nerd
culture became mainstream following a
lukewarm response to the first few
seasons the series eventually found its
audience and broke several records in
2018 the show's four leads Jim Parsons
Johnny Galecki Simon Helberg and all
Nayer were the highest paid actors on TV
just one of the many ways that the Big
Bang Theory is a lot like friends as
many critics have stated in 2019 12
years after its premiere on CBS The Big
Bang Theory became the longest running
multi-camera sitcom surpassing the
previous record of 275 episodes set by
cheers but by then Parsons had already
turned down a reported 50 million
dollars to make two more seasons which
is the real reason why the Big Bang
Theory ended after the 12th season aired
in 2019 as both celebration and mockery
of geek culture the show usually wasn't
subtle about its references but there
were probably a few things you never
noticed in the TV hits final episode The
Big Bang Theory first aired at the peak
of 2000's fashion when Ugg boots and
pleated mini skirts were the look twelve
years later the trends may have changed
but the show's costume Department snuck
in a few references to the pilot to show
how the characters lives have come full
circle Sheldon's t-shirts have always
been a talking point especially now that
Superhero merch is more present at big
box chain stores than ever in the first
half of the finale the change constant
Sheldon is wearing one of his Classic
t-shirts bearing the Green Lantern logo
however the t-shirt is deliberately
faded emphasizing the passing of time
and the fact that his clothing is yet
another thing that he can't keep from
changing in the second half of the
finale the Stockholm syndrome Sheldon
wears a t-shirt showing multiple
superhero logos which is unusual for him
this matches the feel of the episode as
a conclusion of the whole series The
Sheldon finally learning to appreciate
his friends instead of thinking about
himself all the time Sheldon isn't the
only one whose t-shirt is talking in the
final shot look closer at Penny's light
blue top with purple flowers and you'll
see that it's the same one she wore when
she first met Sheldon and Leonard Penny
also wore this top when Leonard asked
her on a date that led to them
rekindling their relationship in season
five it's a nice way to connect the
pivotal moments in a relationship that
has been at the heart of the show from
day one there's another Penny Leonard
connection between the pilot and finale
in the Stockholm syndrome Penny reveals
that she's pregnant the couple's
decision over whether to have children
is a thread throughout the final season
but it's actually been in the cards for
a lot longer you likely never noticed in
the Big Bang Theory's first episode that
Leonard predicted this plot line in the
pilot immediately after meeting Penny he
told Sheldon our babies will be smart
and beautiful
foreign
we'll have to wait 20 years or so for
the inevitable Revival to find out
whether or not this assessment is true
but it also marked an unusual moment for
Sheldon his response to Leonard's
prediction is not to mention imaginary
even Nobel prize-winning theoretical
physicists can't be right all the time
of the four main men on The Big Bang
Theory Raj kruthapali played by Kunal
Nair was perhaps the most socially
awkward raja's difficulties with women
resulted in some painfully uncomfortable
situations one of which involved Raj
doing the absolute worst thing he's ever
done
you went out with him I didn't
throughout the Big Bang Theory Raj the
self-proclaimed romantic of the group
tries to have a successful relationship
with a woman but Falls horribly short
for a number of reasons on more than one
occasion he requests that his parents
organize an arranged marriage with a
woman from a good Indian family and
every single one of them ends up failing
miserably a list of his other romantic
mishaps include dating two women at once
rifling through a girl's closets and
drawers when she leaves him alone in her
house leaving one girl for another after
the briefest of meetings with the latter
and then coming crawling back to his ex
when a girl turns him away pushing women
way out of their comfort zone referring
to women he's not attracted to as
fatties and uggos and spying on his
fiancee and that's not even to mention
him fantasizing about his friends wives
and girlfriends throughout the show even
almost hooking up with Penny one night
what were you thinking easily the worst
thing Raj did however was the Isabella
on the season 10 episode entitled The
Brain Bowl incubation Raj meets the
beautiful maintenance worker when she
comes into his lab at Caltech to clean
late one night despite the instant spark
between them it becomes clear that Raj
has a problem with Bella's job after
hitting it off with Isabel in his lab
Raj helps her clean the bathrooms during
their cleaning session he decides to ask
Isabella on a date but she explains she
doesn't have time to date while working
two jobs before leaving the bathroom he
tries to convince Isabella to change her
mind and she again turns him down the
rest of the gang quickly picks up on the
fact that Raj has met someone you're
dating somebody who is it barrage makes
a fatal and cruel mistake when he fails
to correct their assumption that she's
also an astronomer uh what for a
supposedly intelligent man this is a
stupid move still Raj Cooks up a plan to
surprise her and get the date he wants
it's a little pushy and desperate after
she's already turned him down twice in
the bathroom when Isabella next walks
into his lab he set up a romantic dinner
complete with flowers and a tablecloth
for them to enjoy things seem to be
going swimmingly and then Howard walks
in and casually mentions oh yeah the
astronomer Raj told us about you you can
actually see Isabella's face ball as she
instantly realizes raja's lied about her
job and rightly points out that she
doesn't need to waste her time with
someone who's embarrassed by what she
does for a living she makes a quick exit
from the lab dragging her cleaning cart
with her as she goes
Raj tries to go after Isabella and
apologize saying he couldn't believe how
shallow he was being honestly I I didn't
think your job would bother me but I
guess it did and I hate myself for that
fortunately Isabella has enough respect
for herself to walk away from someone
who clearly won't respect her Raj knew
what Isabella did before he even started
pursuing her and continued to chase her
knowing full well he would never be
comfortable telling his friends that
she's a cleaning lady at the University
and not another scientist what exactly
did he think was going to happen it's
such a blatant lie that there's no way
anyone will convince us Raj truly
thought their relationship would be able
to go anywhere without the LIE coming
out the shami felt over Isabella's job
is even more ironic when we consider the
fact that at that point in time Raj was
still living off his father's Fortune to
pay for his rent made car and credit
card bills something he seems oddly
proud of I grew up with the hospital
servants and now I'm a cleaning lady
who is a lovely woman who I have great
respect for at least Isabella is making
a living off her own money Raj really
has no leg to stand on with this
classism here my defense I have a car
whose doors open like this oh I'm sorry
it's never acceptable to make someone
else feel ashamed about what they do and
Raj hit rock bottom with his treatment
of Isabella during this episode of The
Big Bang Theory watching him lie to his
friends about Isabella's job makes it
easy to understand why Raj has so many
problems with women jealousy over money
social media shade Nerds Collide oh my
was there more surface tension on the
set of The Big Bang Theory than we first
realized keep watching for what you need
to know about Kaley Cuoco and Mayim
bialik's real relationship
at its heart The Big Bang Theory is a
show about friendship while it's true
that the series essentially follows a
group of socially awkward nerds
friendship is an important part of daily
lives of Mega nerd Sheldon Cooper and
his like-minded companions among plenty
of other notable friendships the pairing
of Penny played by Kaley Cuoco and Amy
played by Mayim Bialik stands out as one
of the show's most prominent though the
two have quite a difficult time getting
to know one another after Amy is first
introduced in season three by the end of
the series they're as thick as thieves
in spite of their many differences
however some online gossip has suggested
that the actors who play these two
characters might not be as chummy as
their on-screen counterparts in fact
rumors swirled for years regarding a
possible onset feud between Cuoco and
Bialik some gossip websites have even
alleged that the stars were once
embroiled in a so-called cat fight and
that the two once had to be physically
separated from each other as is often
the case when it comes to celebrity
gossip there's apparently not much
Credence to these claims in fact it's
fair to say that Bialik and kwoko seem
to share a solid friendship in real life
as well as on screen
well obviously the cast we had great
chemistry from the beginning while
rumors of a feud between Kaley Cuoco and
Mayim Bialik may be entertaining and at
least somewhat plausible they're not
entirely accurate of course it's not
unheard of for cast members on a
long-running series like The Big Bang
Theory to develop some animosity
especially when large sums of money are
involved in fact money happens to be the
cause of the rumor in question which
reportedly emerged due to a massive pay
gap between the show's original and
Later cast members more specifically
these rumors claim the Bialik made one
hundred thousand dollars an episode
while Cuoco made one million dollars
which upset Bialik however many of the
Articles discussing these rumors list no
real sources to back up their claims
meanwhile evidence of Cuoco and bialik's
real-life friendship seems much more
credible for example according to
variety Cuoco and the other Original Big
Bang Theory co-stars took pay cuts in
2017 to increase the paychecks of both
Bialik and Melissa Roush who plays
Bernadette on the show while Cuoco and
the other original Stars still made much
more money than their newer counterparts
their pay cuts were an important gesture
regardless of a potentially significant
pay gap between the two actors it seems
that they're friends in real life when
Cuoco got married to her now ex-husband
Carl cook in 2018 Bialik was notably one
of the few Big Bang Theory cast members
to actually attend the ceremony as a
result it seems apparent that the two
are closer than certain rumors may
suggest Mayan Bialik herself once
addressed the subject of her
relationship with Kaylee Cuoco firsthand
during a video interview with wired as
part of a series in which participants
are asked some of the most searched
questions about themselves Bialik
responded directly to whether or not she
and kwoko are friends
well we worked together for nine years
and I went to her wedding and celebrated
things with her I would say we're
friends
furthermore Bialik and Cuoco both
participated in a cast reunion in glamor
magazine to commemorate the book The Big
Bang Theory the definitive inside story
of the Epic hit series
while it certainly seems as though a
friendship between the two actors exists
it's also possible that vialik and kwoko
may not be as close as they have
publicly implied specifically one Reddit
user pointed out that Cuoco doesn't
follow Bialik on Instagram in spite of
the fact that Bialik follows Cuoco and
once tagged her in a photo in short the
rumored animosity between Bialik and
kwoko seems to be overblown nevertheless
the Instagram discrepancy suggests that
a certain degree of tension could exist
between the two actors perhaps they're
just two people who don't necessarily
see eye to eye but work together on one
of the most popular TV shows of all time
it takes the show a while to get the
Kinks out and the Big Bang Theory is no
exception here are all the weird things
you might not have realized about the
first episode of The Big Bang Theory the
first scene in the first episode of The
Big Bang Theory begins with the setting
never seen on the series again and
broaching a topic that's never explored
further concerned about growing old
before passing on their science genius
genes Sheldon and Leonard visit a sperm
bank one that only accepts the genetic
material of the highly intelligent and
exceptional while that's very much in
character with Sheldon's outspoken
vanity and pride in his Superior
intellect it clashes mightily with how
he's depicted for most of the rest of
the series which is someone adverse to
any and all kinds of sexual and physical
Behavior it's a little weird to see the
almost always libido free shelled and
openly talk about and be open to
providing a sample of a sperm bank it's
even stranger later in the episode when
the famously awkward Sheldon considers
the possibility of coupling up with
penny in the same way that Sheldon is
more of a red-blooded sexual being than
he'd wind up being for most of the Big
Bang Theory Penny isn't quite right at
the beginning of the show She Moves In
across the hall from Leonard and Sheldon
and the former is smitten with her after
their first meeting sure she's
conventionally attractive but penny is
also very likable she's friendly she's
bubbly and she's curious about her new
building mates this isn't the penny that
Kaley Cuoco would play later on before
long Penny would get a lot less Lively
and a lot more cynical perhaps hanging
out with all those fussy exhausting high
maintenance nerds day in and day out
killed her spirit along with that tiring
job as a chain restaurant waitress sent
into moralizing ultimately failed career
as an actress plus Penny defies the
stereotypical dumb blonde archetype
she's supposed to embody by revealing in
the pilot that she's written screenplay
the idea of Penny's potential double
threats as a performer and a writer is
never mentioned again and her
screenwriting talents were quickly
abandoned maybe the most notable thing
about the first episode of The Big Bang
Theory is and what's there but what
isn't there or rather who isn't nearly
half of the show's core long-term cast
members weren't yet a part of the series
Kevin Sussman didn't make his first
appearance as Sad Sack comic store owner
Stewarts until the end of season two
Melissa Roush didn't join the series as
microbiologist Bernadette rostinkowski
until the start of season three and Maya
Bialik didn't portray neurologist Amy
Farah Fowler until the end of season
three that means none of them show up or
even Merit a mention in the first
episode of The Big Bang Theory that
gives the episode of sparse feel it's
just really quiet and simple with only
five main characters plus after so many
episodes about romantic entanglements
Sheldon and Amy Howard and Bernadette
Leonard Penny it's the rare episode of
The Big Bang Theory that isn't entirely
about a couple The Big Bang Theory could
be characterized as a quick moving rapid
fire show the setups and punch lines
come at the viewer fast as do scene
changes with that distinctive
transitional graphic of an atomic model
accompanied by a whoosh sound effect
plus the average Big Bang episode
incorporates a lot of scenes at several
locations generally including the main
apartment set the one across the hall
some Caltech offices the cafeteria power
and Bernadette's house and a few other
spots however that formats in its fast
flow weren't in place in the first
episode The Pilot feels more like a play
clearly separated into three acts and
only a handful of scenes and they're all
about as long as the scene can be in a
half hour sitcom the episode begins with
a pre-themed song Cold open that
stretches to a whopping six minute scene
after that it's on to the guy's
apartment where the vast majority of the
episode takes place based on his
behavior in the first episode of The Big
Bang Theory it's hard to get a handle on
Raj koothupali no trace of his future
character arcs are present not his
desire for a grand and epic romance nor
his slow acceptance of his own fate and
his move away from dependence on his
wealthy parents that's because Raj a
main character in most episodes of The
Big Bang Theory has about two lines in
the show's pilot episode
wait till you see this it's fantastic
unbelievable this is explained away with
this early work of being too shy to talk
to women without the aid of alcoholic
beverages but still it's odd and
surprising that he barely talks Raj even
dresses differently wearing a baseball
cap with his regular nerdy outfit
although many ingredients that would
make the Big Bang Theory such a
resounding long-running success weren't
yet present in the Show's first episode
The Writers did show some foresight like
other situation comedies about groups of
young Friends The Big Bang Theory is
about a social group that forms it de
facto family and it evoked that idea
week after week by having the whole gang
Gathering to eat together like a family
dinner it was a powerful statement and
the cast eating takeout with one another
became one of the definitive enduring
images of The Big Bang Theory over the
years it was also the very last scene of
the very last episode of the series
creating a parallel with the first
episode where Sheldon and Leonard
invited Penny into their family by
asking her to eat with them oh you're
inviting me over to eat uh yes oh that's
so nice I'd love to Plus in the pilot
episode Leonard watches Penny walk away
and then he proclaims they will one day
have babies that quote will be smart and
beautiful thanks to their mesh jeans in
the finale married Penny and Leonard
learned they've got a baby on the way
though Sheldon mocked Leonard for this
declaration in the pilot he uses his
Nobel Prize except in speech in the
finale to note that his friend was right
he said to me that their babies would be
smart and beautiful
and now that they're expecting I have no
doubt that that will be the case
which Big Bang Theory characters went
out smiling and which ones had truly
terrible finales here are the endings of
every major Big Bang Theory character
ranked from worst to best
because not all character endings are
created equal
by season 7 love sick and lonely Raj
played by Kunal Nair has completely
given up on meeting women by traditional
methods in favor of online dating until
enter Emily Sweeney played by Laura
Spencer after Emily sends a message to
Raj the two begin a slowly developing
relationship the news that Raj has a
steady girlfriend is so huge in fact
that the Big Bang Theory treats it as a
bigger deal than when Leonard and Penny
announced their engagement
sadly in season 9 Raj messes up a good
thing dumping Emily to pursue new
possibilities in the name of Claire
played by Alessandra torresani of course
as you might have already guessed Claire
rejects poor Raj
Emily shows up just enough to remind
viewers she's moved on with a new
boyfriend and that intimacy problems
with Raj helped Doom their relationship
from the beginning all this makes
Emily's finale more of a bust than a
bang
when the show started the four male
characters on The Big Bang Theory all at
very different approaches when it came
to hooking up with members of the
opposite sex hi hi hi hi hi
Howard played by Simon hellberg wanted
cheap tawdry physical Pleasures Leonard
hofstetter played by Johnny Galecki only
wanted to be with Kaylee Cuoco who
played Penny of course Sheldon played by
Jim Parsons found the whole notion of
romance a strange distraction from his
scientific work would you be open to
rotating the couch clockwise 30 degrees
meanwhile Raj harbored an innocent
dreamy fairy tale idea of romance
ironically he was the one who struggled
the most with his love life
over time Raj maintained a few
relationships
Lucy played by Kate micucci Emily played
by Katie Leclair and of course Claire
and the other Emily
still when a character's whole goal is
to seek out love it's disappointing they
don't get to have it when their show
ends in the final episode Raj even pays
Sarah Michelle Geller of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer to attend Sheldon and
Amy's Nobel Prize ceremony as his date
is that Buffy the Vampire Slayer
which is just plain sad
Melissa Rauch first popped up as
Bernadette on The Big Bang Theory early
in season three when she was set up with
Howard the two hit it off and a few
episodes later Roush permanently joined
the cast over the course of the show
Bernadette progresses in both her work
life and personal life
starting out as a Cheesecake Factory
server alongside Penny to pay for her
doctorate Bernadette eventually becomes
a well-paid and highly regarded
researcher at a pharmaceutical company
Bernadette marries Howard at the end of
season five and five years later they
welcomed their first daughter Hallie
before long baby Neil is born and that
makes four in the household
Bernadette's story is maintained for the
final season of The Big Bang Theory
where she's a harried working mother of
two dealing with day-to-day stressors
without too much really happening with
the character
for most of his run on The Big Bang
Theory Stuart Bloom played by Kevin
Sussman remained a steady unchanging
character Stewart serves as a worst case
scenario comparison for the main
characters if they consider themselves
nerds who have a hard time attracting
women and interacting with mainstream
Society Stuart shows them that their
situation could be a lot worse look at
me I'm 37 if I sleep in the back of a
comic book store and I have the bone
density of an 80 year old man he's the
owner of the Big Bang boys favorite
comic book store a guy who freely
discusses his fears and anxieties about
the store closing and leaving him an
economic ruin as well as his inability
to maintain any sort of romantic
relationship with the opposite sex
in other words he's the geek shunned by
the other Geeks and the major characters
keep him at arm's length as if his bad
luck is contagious by the big bang
theories finale however Stewart has
finally found love admitting his
feelings for comic store employee Denise
played by Lauren Lapkus who returns the
sentiment you are so hot but neither are
considered close enough to the gang to
attend the Nobel Prize ceremony in
Sweden instead they stay in California
to babysit Howard and Bernadette's kids
which in classic Stuart fashion is a
disaster
Penny seems happy at the conclusion of
The Big Bang Theory but is she really
comparing the penny at the end of the
show to the one at the beginning reveals
a changed woman and not necessarily for
the better I'm also writing a screenplay
it's about this sensitive girl who comes
to LA from Lincoln Nebraska to be an
actress and winds up a waitress at the
Cheesecake Factory when she moves across
the hall from Sheldon and Leonard she's
bubbly friendly and fueled by her dream
of becoming an actress and screenwriter
but as the show goes on Penny's
character begins to change dealing with
a fussy rude Sheldon and a tumultuous
relationship with Leonard turns her into
the show's source of put downs and eye
rolling often with a large glass of wine
to cope with what her life has become
apart from roles in a few humiliating B
movies and commercials Penny never does
make it as an actress she abandons that
career for a more lucrative but less
fulfilling one is a pharmaceutical rap
at least her romantic life settles down
Penny marries Leonard who worships the
ground she walks on in the final episode
Penny tells her husband that she's
pregnant despite making it clear that
she had no intention of becoming a
mother in the end nothing turned out the
way it was supposed to for Penny
only one person on The Big Bang Theory
absolutely hates Sheldon and he isn't
afraid to let him know yeah we're
talking about fellow Caltech scientists
Barry Kripke played by John Ross Bowie
he's the workplace equivalent of a
schoolyard bully who taunts Cooper
grippy yes you're in my spot in the
final season Kripke gets his Redemption
and he gets to mock Sheldon one last
time even though Sheldon rejects his
request to fund a project he offers to
help Sheldon prove that one of his
Rivals for the Nobel Prize is a fraud
later when Sheldon is awaiting the phone
call to see if he won that very big
honor Kripke prank calls him pretending
to be the organizers from Sweden and
that's how Kripke goes out teasing
Sheldon until the very end
The Big Bang Theory scored a major cast
in coup when Mayim B ollic joined the
cast in season three like castmate and
ex-rose and star Johnny Galecki Bialik
was a former teen sitcom actor familiar
to Millions as the title character on
Blossom additionally Bialik studied in a
field similar to that of her character
on The Big Bang Theory Amy Farah Fowler
as it turns out the performer has a
doctorate in neurobiology adding some
realism to her role as a neuroscientist
I I got my PhD in in Neuroscience from
UCLA in her early appearances Amy is
quiet and lonely with no one in her life
except for her lab animals Big Bang
Theory writers however leaned into the
idea of having Amy be a match for the
also forever solo Sheldon Cooper
eventually the romantically driven Amy
gets Sheldon to do things he's never
considered doing like kissing and
getting married it's no surprise that
such a logical direct character would
wind up getting exactly what she wants
the ideal husband to match the ideal
career in the final episode of the
series Amy achieves what only a handful
of scientists ever do she wins a Nobel
Prize to say to all the young girls out
there who dream about science as a
profession
Go For It sharing the nod with you
guessed it Sheldon
before she winds up with Leonard Penny
brings a few guys home to meet her
friends Zach Johnson played with relish
by Brian Thomas Smith is a classic
sitcom jock big athletic good looking
but also noticeably stupid one question
I'll keep you sure it won't blow up
the laser the moon like a human version
of a dog Zach is dumb but he doesn't
care plus he's friendly to everyone
feeling threatened by this man who
represented every high school bully who
ever dunked them into a toilet or trash
can the cast of Geeks insult him to his
face and talk bad about him behind his
back
Zach gets the happy ending he deserves
he forms a menu design company and sells
it for Millions he also gets over Penny
and marries a woman named Marissa played
by Lindsay Kraft who is just as dim and
kind as he is
while Sheldon Cooper endures the nasty
childish taunts and pranks of Barry
Kripke his true enemy is Will Wheaton
the former Child Star who played Wesley
Crusher on Sheldon's beloved Star Trek
the Next Generation so what's up with
the hatred well Wheaton failed to show
up for an autograph session Shelton
worked hard to attend Whedon played
himself over several episodes of The Big
Bang Theory usually to gleefully
antagonize Sheldon for example in a card
game tournament he explains that he
missed that fateful autograph session to
be with his sick grandmother and Sheldon
close to his own Grandmom lets his guard
down in a rare show of empathy leading
Wheaton to win even though Wheaton was
lying about his grandmother the whole
time I call my memo on Nana
and she's going to be very happy to hear
that my small rock kills your Enchanted
bunny in the final season of The Big
Bang Theory the characters square off
once more when both are going to play
children's science show host Professor
Proton a role that opened up after the
death of the original actor played by
Bob Newhart Wheaton rightfully gets the
gig devastating Sheldon A fitting end
for the well-qualified Rogue
Leonard hofstadter is a brilliant
scientist with a lot to brag about he
has workplace accomplishments and makes
major scientific achievements ultimately
the prestigious Caltech researcher has
one goal above else he wants to wind up
hitch to Penny and live happily ever
after in the big bang theories pilot
Leonard claims he's going to have
children with Penny someday our babies
will be smart and beautiful and after
some initial disinterest on her part
some will they won't they ups and downs
the pair finally get hitched and
officially settle however there's one
major issue in the pairing between the
energetic actress and the goofy
scientist he wants to start a family she
doesn't in the finale however Penny
excitedly tells Leonard that she's
expecting someone's gonna figure it out
when we just tell people oh it's too
early I haven't even wrap my head around
it I have my head is wrapped that means
Leonard gets his dream woman along with
his prophecy fulfilled too it's yet
another win for Leonard on top of all
that near the end of the series Leonard
reconciles his tense and cold
relationship with his intimidating
mother psychiatrist and neuroscientist
Dr Beverly hofstetter played by
Christine baransky so
I forgive you way to go Leonard
the one character that changes the most
throughout the 12-season Run of The Big
Bang Theory who gets to enjoy one of the
most definitive accomplished and
meaningful endings is Howard Wolowitz
way back in season one Howard was the
closest thing the show had to a villain
it's unsettling how he relentlessly hit
on Penny even though she stated several
times that she found both the man and
his method unattractive and repulsive
you may be familiar with some of my work
it's currently orbiting Jupiter's
largest moon taking high resolution
digital photographs for years Howard
stayed a revolting sex-obsessed creep
who hit on any woman he saw never mind
he never actually attracted a woman to
his sleazy bedroom in the house he
shared with his overbearing mother
however the Howard at the end of The Big
Bang Theory is a different man entirely
by then he's been happily married for
years to Bernadette and he does his best
to make her happy the only other female
on his radar is his toddler daughter
Hallie he's also established a
successful career as a scientist and
engineer the dude even went to space
with NASA how's that for a big bang
ending
while the Big Bang Theory is a sitcom
about a group of scientists who are best
friends it's really the story of one man
Sheldon Cooper they can't function
without me I'm the social clue that
holds this little group together never
before had a sitcom as Broad and
mainstream as this attempted to include
a main character who is one of the
smartest people in the world that's
because sitcom characters are generally
both relatable and amiable and Sheldon
is well neither of those things after
graduating from college as a teenager he
went on to study the secrets of the
universe as a theoretical physicist he
may be proven a smarty pants but for
most of the Big Bangs run Sheldon's
social skills were about as Charming as
a moon rock Sheldon I'm not ready to
have a baby oh yes you are I track your
cycle over the 12 Seasons however
Sheldon Cooper learns how to be a
conscientious person even if at a
snail's pace and in the 2 part series
finale Sheldon wins a Nobel Prize the
ultimate recognition for a high-end
researcher of his caliber and a crowning
achievement in a career full of
scientific breakthroughs the episodes
climax is an emotional one when Sheldon
uses part of his speech to express at
long last profound gratitude for his
friends and wife and Co Nobel Laureate
Amy I wouldn't be up here if it weren't
for some very important people in my
life
foreign
[Music]